(upbeat music)
(record scratching)
(classical music)
- You have to take
into account, guys, that we're
using very thick tipped pens.
(Emma snorts)
So it is just a little bit
harder to get the nuance
and detail that I would usually achieve
if I was with my pencil set.
- (laughs) You're making
me laugh.
(bell dings)
- We're going to draw each other.
Fun little activity.
- We're gonna draw each other for Netflix.
Watch "Sex Education."
So let's just get it going.
- [Asa] Let's just go.
- [Ncuti] Let's just get it going.
- Pressure is immense.
- It's tremendous.
- I'm actually quite stressed.
- Can't be rubbing out already.
- Yeah, me too.
- I'm not looking.
(Kedar scoffs)
(Connor groans)
- [Kedar] Innit.
- Aw, this is quite actually hard,
this is stressful.
- Don't stress!
- Aw, I don't like my lines.
- Your hair is gorgeous.
- Oh, thanks.
Took about three hours.
(Patricia chuckles)
What would you do if I turned it round
and it was just like a picture of a sheep?
(sheep bleating)
- Are you doing caricatures or you,
oh there you go, now you wanna look.
You've forgotten how I
look, is that how it is?
- Ah, ah.
I'm gonna do it pretty realistic,
it's gonna be pretty spot on--
- You say that, and that
means you're gonna draw
some sort of fucking,
I don't know, I don't want to say it.
- I'm wanna get the strength of jaw in.
- (laughs) The strength of jaw.
Can get the strength, it's
quite easy, just draw a square.
- (laughs) I'm stressed.
- Oh my god, I've drawn Steve Harrington!
- [Emma] Stop it!
- I have!
- I expect something nice, Ncuti.
- Okay, do you know what?
I'm just gonna do a--
- Just draw from your heart.
- I'm gonna start--
- Don't even look at me,
just draw from your heart.
- Do you reckon?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- [Asa] Them nice lips.
(bell dings)
- Actually, once you start.
- You promise you're
still gonna be my friend?
- Oh my god, I was just about
to say exactly the same thing!
I'm not even joking.
- Ready?
- Who do we show first?
The camera?
You saw.
- But I don't have my glasses on.
- Three.
- [Ncuti] Two, one.
(both laughing)
- That's actually really good.
Should we sign them or what?
- Yeah, sign it.
- Should we sign it?
(Emma laughs)
- It's Steve Harrington.
That's good!
- It's not.
This is, (laughs) this is.
But do you know what I appreciate?
I really appreciate the brow
and the lash action on this.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I really
made an effort today.
- Yeah.
(Kedar laughs)
- Why, I mean,
to be honest.
- I'm disappointed.
Can you talk me through that?
I mean, it's uncanny.
- That's not me, (laughs)
why is my chin so sharp?
- Okay, the chin was a little off.
- I'll cut someone.
- And the neck's
a little skinny.
- Yeah. (laughs)
Fucking hell, who is that?
- I'm not mad.
I'm not mad.
You've got the mustache there,
you've got the luscious lips there.
(lips smacking)
And my eyebrows are all right.
Hold on, let me just fix it.
- Oh my god.
You've made me haggard.
I look like--
- No, these are cheekbone.
Cheekbones.
- Eat your heart out, "Art Attack."
- Connor and Kedar.
- Thanks for watching.
(Ncuti laughs)
- Should we start an art show?
- Yeah.
But, yeah, we'll have pencils.
- [Emma] Yeah.